wir kommen zur heute schon da sind wir
wieder und wer diese sendung regelmäßig
guckt spürt irgendwas ist heute anders
richtig das studiopublikum fehlt auch
die heute show will natürlich kein
kontakthof für corona viren seien hier
sitzen deswegen tatsächlich nur noch
unsere studio feuerwehr hallo
der hausmeister unsere autoren natürlich
und der typ der normalerweise das
publikum einheizt lass gut sein thomas
mann muss die stelle auch mal aushalten
und es passt ja zur gesamtstimmung
corona beherrscht endgültig unser
öffentliches leben nur noch corona kommt
überhaupt nicht mehr hinterher bei den
vielen corona nachrichten und inzwischen
nehmen es die meisten deutschen auch
sehr ernst also wie gesagt die meisten
das ist ja ich war so wie jede andere
grippe auch ne ich fast alles an ihm ist
dass drei uhr früh da mache ich mir
keinen kopf des corona virus ich will
und werde weiter feiern gehen völlig
richtig um drei uhr morgens da steckt
man sich nicht mehr an
denn sie ihren gehen bekanntlich
spätestens halb drei ins bett corona und
du weißt es wird ernst wenn sich sogar
die bundeskanzlerin in die debatte
einschaltet fast wie so eine
regierungschefin
ich persönlich hätte mir von er zwar
diese woche etwas mehr beruhigung
gewünscht also im grunde eine prise wir
schaffen das aber dafür gab es tolle
ratschläge die man sonst nirgendwo
kriegt dann gucke ich mir noch immer
nicht da so oft darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat mir an wie viele von ihnen
sich irgendwie die hand im gesicht haben
braucht man ja nicht haben soll
das wollen wir auch einige aufgrund
meiner frage liste kann ich jetzt schon
sehen dass es viele viele fragen gibt
jede bitten also eine frage und
gegebenfalls von der nachfrage zu
stellen ja gut das kann man gar nicht
kontrollieren das kann man nicht dieses
ständig ins gesicht fassen das ist ja
ein uralter instinkt wahrscheinlich noch
aus unserer affen phase in das passiert
einfach das passiert ansonsten hat frau
merkel in ihrem volk geraten weniger
hände zu schütteln und dafür
zitat der kanzlerin mehr zu lächeln ja
das sagt die richtige ja aber klar es
ist schon richtig man ist total
verunsichert jeden tag neue zahlen
prognosen hiobsbotschaften da brennen
den deutschen natürlich fragen auf den
nägeln
wenn man sich die hände wäscht die mit
dem virus behaftet sind werden dann die
wir nicht über das abwassersystem
verteilt in der tat sie werden über das
abwassersystem verteilt und das ist gut
so
es sei denn man macht mit diesem
abwasser noch irgendwas anderes wovon
nicht abraten würde ja ich auch wobei
ich jetzt wenig leute kenne die sich mit
dem was in der dusche stehen bleibt noch
eine tasse tee aufbrühen ab montag
machen fast alle schulen dicht so gut
wie alle schulen stand heute das wird
eine echte herausforderung wohin mit dem
ganzen plagen und ich weiß genau was sie
zu hause jetzt denken nein man kann die
nicht alle bis ostern ins ikea small
anbringen vor allem die abiturienten
haben da keinen bock drauf was wir jetzt
gerade erleben ist vor allem die stunde
der virologen ja normalerweise
lichtscheue gesellen die in
unterirdischen laboren irgendwas vor
sich hin forschen jetzt plötzlich sollen
sie ständig interviews geben also im
wurde dem einfachen volk in simplen
worten erklären worauf es jetzt ankommt
es handelt sich einmal um impfstoffe
fern nah oder der basis die molekularen
interaktionen an der virus wirtz inter
phase die wirtszelle proteasen die
dieses protein die dreidimensionale
struktur eines schlüsselenzym müssen
riet ab s im upload der sogenannten
alpha kette mide
ich brauche mehr details verstehe die
wirths inter phase muss natürlich in die
protea vor der lage drauf kommen können
ansonsten diskutieren experten ob wir
aktuell genug machen
manche sagen wir müssten viel mehr
menschen testen während die menschen
selber in supermärkten weiter ums letzte
klopapier kämpfen
warum auch immer es bleibt ein rätsel
sicher ist nur eins deutsche
föderalismus und pandemie passen nicht
zusammen beispiel warum haben wir nicht
in ganz deutschland diese tollen drive
in tests der sie in baden württemberg
machen ja da vereine wie bei mcdonald's
und sagt einen neuen hut schicken
mcnuggets und ein grüner test zum
mitnehmen
ja für einen euro mehr schneiden sie
sogar noch die nasenhaare warum nicht
überall gerade beim thema tests ist
deutschland tatsächlich ein totaler
flickenteppich ist nicht übertrieben
jeder macht es anders jeder regel ist
anders und bürgermeister und landräte
treffen fast alle wichtigen
entscheidungen für realismus also jetzt
ausdrücklich nichts gegen landräte ganz
im gegenteil vor allem der vom kreis
heinsberg ist mein persönlicher held
ohne scheiß jetzt man muss sich selber
auch immer wieder motivieren und sich
selber mut machen und auch vor allen
dingen im auge behalten dass das ja auch
irgendwann vorbei ist als ich habe heute
morgen nochmal udo lindenberg gehört da
singt er dann selbst der härteste scheiß
ist irgendwann wieder vorbei da hat
dieser mann völlig recht die frage ist
nur wann der scheiß vorbei ist wann alle
hoffen ja dass man die infizierung welle
irgendwie verlangsamen kann irgendwie
verlangsamt und bis dahin gilt halt das
alte föderalismus motto jedes bundesland
kämpft für sich allein
das land nrw hat jetzt eine million
atemschutzmasken geordert woher bleibt
ein geheimnis
dieser wurde bestellt habe weil ich
würde das um so dass noch andere erst
dann würde ich meiner haben und dann und
dann können die aussies formlose auch
welche kaufen der laumann
außerdem fürchten jetzt natürlich alle
die große wirtschaftskrise nicht ohne
grund in dieser schwarzen woche haben
die börsianer in frankfurt mehrmals ein
ziemlich trauriges dax face gemacht so
nennen die jungen leute das dax fest
gestern gab es den zweitgrößten
tagesverlust in der dax geschichte gut
das hat natürlich auch immer viel mit
herdentrieb zu tun
nach dem motto angst essen börse auf das
corona virus hat ratz fatz sämtliche
aktien gewinne der letzten vier jahre
komplett
aufgefuttert komplett und besonders
schwer getroffen hat es ausgerechnet die
deutsche bank die deutsche bank welche
ironie
die wollten eigentlich diese woche ihren
150 geburtstag feiern abgesagt
stattdessen haben sie in ganz kleinem
kreis 150 prozent kursverlust bei rhi
aktie gefeiert da war aber auch ganz
schön da konnten sich die kleinaktionäre
endlich mal bedanken
ja die groko unsere groko stemmt sich
mit kurzarbeitergeld gegen die rezession
und seit heute gibt es ein unbegrenztes
kredit versprechen für angeschlagene
branchen unbegrenzt das heißt unser
alter freund die schwarze null wird
corona nicht überleben immerhin eine
gute nachricht nach jetzt muss nur noch
irgendwer den tafeln helfen habe ich
heute gelesen
abgesehen davon erleben wir natürlich
ein historisches wochenende die
fußball-bundesliga hat den spielbetrieb
vorerst eingestellt bis ja bis weiß man
nicht bis mindestens zwei unter der
woche gab es ja schon sogenannte geister
spiele vor leeren rängen also fußball
vor leeren ränge wobei das champions
league spiel der leipziger am dienstag
das land noch vor publikum statt und die
laune war bestens sorgen über das virus
hat sich hier kaum jemand gemacht
ja man hat nämlich das gefühl dass man
sich irgendwie anstecken könnte ja klar
das fühlst du noch wenn du die ansteckt
das sind virus ist ein fettes teilen
wenn du das verschluckt das merkst du
sofort fußballfans ab jetzt ruht der
spielbetrieb also wer weiß wie lange
dazu begrüße ich deines knossalla
heute-show experte für unschuldig in not
geratene randsportarten dennis wie hart
wird das für sie persönlich
er hat eine ganze wochenenden ab jetzt
ohne stadion das ist hart stadion
diese einmalige mischung aus emotionen
euphorie und rassismus was sonst ja
links grün die rheiner ins ohr rechts
konzerne auf die schuhe
klar man steht da in der fankurve schon
sehr dicht zusammen
andererseits ist das für viele männer
der einzige körperkontakt der woche naja
aber wir haben halt pandemie
trotzdem sage ich vorsicht
möglicherweise öffnet die bundesliga
hier quasi pandora
buchs und wenn überhaupt muss man das
uns fans doch ein bisschen sensibler
verkaufen mal ernsthaft was bringt der
spanier für wünsche
das ist ein morgens auf dem weg zur
arbeit sind doch auch alle in der u-bahn
möglicherweise beieinander
die entscheidende frage was kann man
leichter verzichten
fußball spielen oder auf dem weg zur
arbeit
was ist das denn für eine bescheuerte
frage kleiner tipp fängt mit an und hört
mit aus also sie würden einfach
weiterspielen weil ihnen die vereine
leid tun
borussia dortmund verliert morgen
maximal drei millionen euro
dafür muss ein mats hummels bis zu 30
minuten arbeiten nein nein nein mir geht
es natürlich um die fans zehntausende
deutsche machen morgen eine völlig neue
erfahrung die irren orientierungslos
durch unsere straßen geben die sozis
kein wunder
diese menschen waren samstagnachmittag
ja noch nie irgendwo anders als im
stadion
was hat man sonst auch machen am
wochenende ich habe mir das erklären
lassen
es gibt wohl erwachsene männer die gehen
mit ihrer frau einkaufen warum das war
sie auch einkaufen mit der frau wie sie
habe ich mir das vorzustellen
[Musik]
du kannst du kannst du kannst ja ist
auch lustig aber keiner satz hätte es
nicht erst einmal gereicht nur bestimmte
fangesänge zu verbieten
die bei denen man automatisch nur
feuchte aussprache hat ja es ist eine
ausnahmesituation da müssen wir jetzt
gemeinsam durch ja sie haben ja recht
wahrscheinlich müssen wir da auch ein
stück weit wachsen werden gibt ja auch
andere tolle sachen meine frau hat zb
vorgeschlagen dass wir morgen einfach
mal eine schöne radtour machen
zusammen mit den kindern dennis
knossalla vielen dank
bezahlt applaus einfach nicht das erhöht
so und für alle die gerade denken
wochenende ohne bundesliga freunde
schlimmer kann es ja wirklich nicht mehr
kommen doch leider doch zb wenn
demnächst zu viele leute in deutschland
gleichzeitig ins krankenhaus müssen
reichen dann personal und betten
also erstmal natürlich schon nach allem
was man hört aber unsere intensivstation
verfügen über 28.000 betten von denen im
schnitt 80 prozent belegt sind wieder da
können sich die pfleger schon ohne
corona nicht über zu viele pausen
beklagen die pflegerin versuchte es mit
humor zu nehmen
langweilig wird's nicht langweilig wird
es hier nie das ist bei uns da habe ich
wirklich nicht das problem
35 hat keine zeit fürs interview wie
unhöflich
da stellt man eine einfache frage und
die leben retten gibt's doch gar nicht
trotz der groko flege offensive sind in
unseren krankenhäusern 17.000 stellen
unbesetzt im letzten jahr fehlten allein
4700 intensivpfleger das wiederum führt
dazu dass in jeder dritten klinik
bereits intensivbetten zeitweise
gesperrt werden und das wiederum ist gar
keine gute nachricht wenn so was wie
corona anklopft was befürchten sie für
die nächsten jahre
johannes selektion eine selektion nach
dem prinzip wer zuerst kommt mahlt
zuerst und wäre halt in so einer phase
wo ganz viele kranke sind kein bett
findet pech gehabt
ja das war gar nicht lustig deutschland
hat bereits jetzt einen der
schlechtesten pflegepatienten schlüssel
in europa bei uns kommt ein pfleger auf
13 patienten in norwegen war zum
vergleich sind es fünf kein wunder dass
laut umfrage 37 prozent unserer
intensivpfleger demnächst aufhören
wollen pflege ist ja generell ein brett
harter job wirklich die ultimative
challenge tagsüber bett fahren slalom
den notfällen auf dem flur ausweichen
nachts alleine die ganze station
betreuen und am nächsten morgen ist man
in der regel selber pflegefall
und das sind halt so systemische
probleme eines auf effizienz getrimmten
gesundheitssystems die jetzt durch
corona vielleicht verschärft werden
andererseits gehört auch zu weit
andererseits im vergleich zu anderen
ländern können wir natürlich schon sehr
froh sein über unser deutsches
gesundheitssystem russland zum beispiel
russland bekämpft corona mit kosaken es
ist kein witz da ist in russland die
kosaken patrouille unterwegs im
russischen jekaterinburg sind die
kosaken unterwegs corona patrouille
wir glauben das virus ist nicht
gefährlich für europäer schwer lesen der
zeitung und facebook dort steht
geschrieben dass die krankheit nur
asiaten befällt ich habe bei facebook
gelesen dass befällt vor allem pelztiere
die sich dann zum sterben auf den kopf
von kosaken zurück sie ja facebook ist
aber immer eine top quelle machst du
nichts verkehrt oder vergleich wir uns
doch mal mit den usa vereinigte staaten
da hat die trump regierung das virus
lange kleingeredet weshalb viel zu wenig
amerikaner getestet wurden oder wer
schuld wenn das da drüben auch eskaliert
bitte ich bin schuld us-präsident trump
wirft europa vor das virus in sein land
eingeschleppt zu haben und verhängte ein
einreiseverbot für alle europäischen
staaten mit ausnahme großbritanniens
natürlich natürlich zu seiner
entschuldigung
trumps gehirn steht schon seit jahren
unter quarantäne und hat keinen klugen
gedanken mehr reingelassen du neid war
doch eine doofe mauer einfach noch höher
dann schaffen es die ausländischen wären
da nicht mehr drüber über 27 millionen
amerikaner haben keine
krankenversicherung aber europa ist
schuld schon klar plus diese
unerträgliche angeberei wo guckt da ich
immer hin während seiner ansprache
wahrscheinlich jeder irgendwo links oben
einen cheeseburger trumps rede diese
intellektuelle arschbombe hat direkt
schockwellen an den börsen der welt
ausgelöst und corona ist endgültig
wahlkampf thema nummer eins in den usa
wir schalten wir live zu unserer washing
korrespondentin valerie niehaus valerie
gefährdet
corona möglicherweise die wiederwahl von
donald trump na sagen wir mal so es ist
wieder spannend seit dieser woche haben
wir im grunde einen dreikampf und das
kandidatenfeld bildet wirklich die ganze
diversität und vielfalt der
amerikanischen gesellschaft ab so
amerika wer soll dein herzblatt sein der
sehr alte sehr weiße joe biden der noch
ältere noch weitere bernie sanders oder
der 73-jährige orangene jungspund donald
zusammen sind sie unglaubliche 228 jahre
ich sag mal so egal wer von den dreien
gewinnt man wird in jedem fall das
amerikanische wappentier neu designen
statt dem klassischen us adler ein adler
im treppenlift vor allem für trump ist
corona ein totaler albtraum der erste
gegner den er nicht mit twitter lügen
klein kriegt er hat schon panisch bei
seinem freund putin angerufen für die
mir kannst du irgendwas schmutziges über
des corona die ruß aus kam
ja das waren dort als größte fehler beim
krisenmanagement na ja er hat tagelang
behauptet das virus sei ein schwindel
der demokraten dann hat er gesagt kein
witz obama sei schuld weil dessen
regierung zu wenig gegen korona gemacht
hat das ganz lustig ist weil obama seit
drei jahren in rente ist und neuerdings
hält er sich tatsächlich für so eine art
medizinisches genie
dabei wurde sie sagt ich soll hätten
absolut das denken wir alle wärst du mal
arzt geworden oder cowboy oder astronaut
jedenfalls nicht präsident ja das wäre
schön
in wirklichkeit macht sich trump doch
viel mehr sorgen um den dow jones index
als um die gesundheit seiner bevölkerung
so hat vor allem habe ich gelesen joe
biden plötzlich wieder echte chancen
also auf joe biden würde ich jetzt
privat erstmal kein geld setzen
stichwort alter der so ist halt wirklich
nicht mehr taufrisch und verwechselt
sachen
[Applaus]
sprecher mit
schwester es gibt landstrich im
mittleren westen genau wie in der eifel
da ist das egal
wie gesagt das wird hier wirklich der
kampf der giganten
da fällt mir ein ich habe jetzt ein
exklusives interview mit der
pressesprecherin von joe biden die
müsste eigentlich da kommt sie ja haben
wir die zeit leider nicht valerie
niehaus ja it-service bruns ich spreche
mit jürgen wie kann ich ihnen
weiterhelfen haben immer versucht das
gerät aus und wieder einzuschalten hat
nichts gebracht verstehe ja probieren
sie doch mal den kanal der heute show
auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung